aquí dibujé una parábola en amarillo y
como vimos en el vídeo pasado una
parábola es el conjunto de puntos que
existan de un punto y de una línea que
hay que estar a la misma distancia del
foco de la parábola que de la directriz
de la parábola y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es usar esta definición de
parábola junto con el hecho de que el
foco de la parábola está en el punto a
ve y la directriz de la parábola es la
recta igual acá vamos a usar estas tres
cosas la definición el foco y la
directriz para sacar cuál es la ecuación
que determina a esta parábola y nos
vamos a tener que meter con álgebra y
vamos a tener unas cuentas un poco
enredadas pero vamos a sacar una
ecuación que determine a esta parábola y
esa ecuación va a estar dada en términos
de a debe y de acá
bueno entonces tomemos un punto por aquí
con coordenadas x dicha y para que ésta
sea una parábola como este punto está en
la parábola entonces este punto es
equidistante al poco y a la directriz y
eso lo único que significa es que la
distancia entre este punto y la
directriz o sea esta línea de azul por
aquí y esta distancia es igual a la
distancia entre este punto y el foco de
la parábola ok a esta distancia de aquí
ahora para sacar la distancia entre este
punto y la directriz como este es una
recta la distancia que es bueno
la longitud más corta entre este punto y
esta recta la podemos encontrar con una
recta que sea perpendicular
perpendicular a la directriz y bueno
para encontrar la distancia entre estos
dos puntos esta distancia de aquí
simplemente tenemos que usar la fórmula
de la distancia no que es bueno
simplemente el teorema de pitágoras
estas dos distancias tienen que ser
iguales entonces vamos a describir eso
por aquí para calcular esta distancia de
aquí realmente solo se involucra la y
entonces tenemos aquí la altura que es
la h y por aquí tenemos el valor de acá
y esta distancia realmente sólo es de
menos acá lo que tenemos por aquí y
menos acá que es la distancia de este
punto a la directriz aunque bueno
tenemos que tener un poco más de cuidado
aquí aunque hay porque si ye menos que
aquí tal cual como lo dibujé con la
parábola hacia arriba y la directriz
aquí abajo ye menos acá es un valor
positivo y todas las distancias tienen
que ser positivas sin embargo si lo
hubiera dibujado diferente por ejemplo
con esta parábola volteada por aquí
debajo de la directriz entonces allá
menos acá sería negativo pero no podemos
tener distancias negativas entonces lo
que realmente queremos
es el valor absoluto de yemen osca sin
embargo el valor absoluto de yemen osca
es exactamente igual a tomar menos que
elevarlo al cuadrado y luego sacar la
raíz cierto bueno y esto de aquí es la
distancia de este punto a la directriz y
para que este punto el punto x esté en
la parábola necesitamos que esa
distancia sea igual a la distancia de
ese punto al foco ok porque esa es la
definición de las parábolas entonces
esta distancia tiene que ser igual a la
distancia entre estos dos puntos y para
sacar la distancia entre estos dos
puntos podemos simplemente usar la
fórmula de la distancia que es el
teorema de pitágoras aunque entonces
aquí te puedes imaginar el triángulo
rectángulo vemos que tan separados están
en la coordenada x o sea x menos
x menos a y lo elevamos al cuadrado
nadas qué tan lejos están en el eje de
las es o sea se me ve que menos ve
elevado al cuadrado y sacamos la raíz de
todo esto y esa es la distancia entre
estos dos puntos que es esta distancia
de aquí listo ya tenemos la ecuación de
la parábola ok esto de aquí aunque se ve
muy enredos o es la ecuación de la
parábola lo único que necesitamos hacer
para poder reconocerlo es simplificar la
y eso es lo que vamos a hacer ahorita
pero si te sientes muy inspirado
adelante simplifica la por tu cuenta que
realmente es nada más álgebra enredosa y
listo vas a reconocer la ecuación de la
parábola en términos de este foco que es
un poco muy general
esta directriz que es una directriz
bastante general aunque hay listos vamos
a simplificar la por aquí tenemos dos
raíces cuadradas entonces lo primero que
se me ocurre es elevar a ambos lados del
igual al cuadrado
así es que aquí lo que nos queda es que
menos acá al cuadrado igual a x menos a
al cuadrado x menos a al cuadrado más
que menos ve al cuadrado y menos al
cuadrado ahora lo que nos gustaría es
que del lado izquierdo del igual sólo
tuviéramos un ancho y del lado derecho
del igual tuviéramos x as veces y casi y
ni una sola y entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es desarrollar todos los
binomios que tienen una y así es que
vamos a empezar por aquí tenemos ya
menos acá al cuadrado y si lo
desarrollamos
ye cuadrado menos 2 y k más cara
cuadrada y eso es igual vamos a dejar
este término que tiene puras x días y
que está muy bien de este lado del igual
vamos a dejarlo sin desarrollar aunque
vamos a dejarlo como x menos a al
cuadrado y este término de aquí tiene un
ayer por lo cual si queremos expandirlo
entonces tenemos más de cuadrada menos 2
de jay más de cuadrada ok lo único que
hice fue multiplicar yemen b por jay
menos 20 gay y así lo desarrollamos
ahora tenemos una cuadrada de los dos
lados del igual entonces podemos
simplemente restar la y se cancelan
ahora aquí tenemos este k cuadrado que
nos gustaría que estuviera del lado
derecho entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
sumar de los dos lados del igual
- que cuadrada aunque si sumamos del
lado izquierdo tenemos que sumar del
lado derecho y este se cancela con este
y por aquí nos queda menos que cuadrada
y también queremos que todas las leyes
estén del lado izquierdo entonces vamos
a sumar por aquí más 2 de que todos ve
que éste se cancela con este y bueno voy
a seguir las ecuaciones de este lado que
tenemos menos 2
dos veces y podemos factorizar un 12
entonces nos quedan dos por b - k
b - acá porque aunque estos dos de aquí
son los que estoy poniendo en amarillo y
esto es igual a x menos a al cuadrado
x menos a al cuadrado más b cuadrada
menos que cuadrada ok más de cuadrada
menos cada cuadrado
ahora la verdad es que nos gustaría que
de este lado se estuviera simplemente
una y entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
dividir todo entre 2 por b menos acá
aunque entonces estas dos se eliminan
nos queda simplemente y ok por aquí
también dividimos entre 2 por b menos
acá y bueno de hecho voy a poner por
aquí estos dos entre 2 por b - acá
entonces esto se elimina con esto y nos
queda simplemente un h igual
1 / 2 x b - k y bueno este paréntesis de
aquí de menos acá es tal cual la
distancia entre el poco
y la directriz pero bueno esto está
multiplicando a x menos a al cuadrado
y bueno si supiéramos cuál es el poco y
cuál es la directriz si supiéramos qué
números son a b y acá entonces esto de
aquí de menos acá sería un número fijo y
por lo tanto todo esto de aquí sería
simplemente un número y ya que opine o
se empieza a aparecer a la ecuación de
una parábola a eso todavía nos falta
sumarle este término de aquí que también
se simplificaría a un simple número pero
además no te parece conocido este
término ve aquí este término lo podemos
escribir como b más acá por b menos acá
y entonces se cancela este paréntesis
con este otro y nos queda simplemente b
más acá b
y que no se nos olvide este medio por
aquí
y medio y listo ya tenemos aquí la
ecuación de la parábola
estuve aquí esta es la ecuación de la
parábola cuyo foco es el punto ave y
cuya directriz es la recta ye igual acá
esta es la ecuación ahora como usamos un
poco y una directriz muy general
entonces podemos usar esta ecuación como
una fórmula que por ejemplo qué pasaría
si tenemos una parábola cuyo foco es el
punto 12 y cuya directriz es la recta de
igual digamos que a menos 1 entonces
cuál es la ecuación de la parábola con
este foco y esta directriz pues lo único
que tenemos que hacer es sustituir estos
valores en la fórmula aunque tenemos que
la ecuación de esta parábola es igual a
1 entre 2
ve - k 2 y k es menos 1 así es que
tenemos dos menos menos 1 y 2 - menos 1
estrés o sea que tenemos aquí dos por
tres
voy a borrar esto y luego tenemos que
multiplicar por x menos o sea x menos 1
al cuadrado más un medio un medio debe
más que sea 2 más menos 1 y 2 más menos
1 es simplemente un 1
la ecuación de esa parábola es igual a 1
entre 6 x x menos 1 al cuadrado más un
medio y listo esta es la ecuación de la
parábola cuyo foco es el punto 12 y cuya
directriz es la recta ye igual a menos 1
y listo